感觉是这样的，
人生有很多很奇妙的际遇，
其实在我们看来啊，
我们是不能理解为什么雇主要送一套房子给你的，
甚至觉得这个是一件非常不可思议的事情，
但可能你就有这样的缘分，
雇主可能觉得我们就玄学一点的说法，
可能就是对你一见如故吧，
可能就是觉得跟你比较亲切，
他愿意送你一套房子，
那作为你的话，
既然受了雇主那么大的恩惠，
那我们工作的时候就是尽心尽力的保证孩子的安全健康，
然后你说很有压力，
这个事情啊，
我觉得只要我秉持着善良，
尽心保证孩子平安健康，
今年33岁，
我老公32岁，
是20岁就结婚了，
有三个孩子，
两个大的是女儿13岁，
9岁，
二个儿子4岁，
我是单亲家庭，
我的妈妈在我四岁就已经病逝了，
原生家庭这一块的话对我是没有任何支撑的，
我跟我老公是常年分居的状态，
10年左右了，
我在深圳，
他在东莞，
孩子是一直爷爷奶奶在大了，
2021年的时候生完我儿子之后，
后面我就回到老家工作了，
距离孩子有40多公里的县城工作，
为什么选择在县城工作，
我是为了方便以后我回家看孩子，
工作也有两年多了，
是做那个住家保姆，
一个月的话是有5500这个雇主。
对我非常的好，
他在我入职一个多月的时候，
他就帮我还清了我个人所有的债务，
是有4万块钱左右，
雇主主动帮你还债，
是我带着这个小孩的妈妈，
在入职一个多月时候啊，
我就跟他和我然间谈起，
我说我我家那边啊，
想要做那种自建房，
然后她就劝我，
建议我为了孩子长远考虑，
不要再建农村的房子，
要考虑到孩子以后的教育问题，
他建议我在深圳啊，
不是在县城买房，
因为资金有限，
因为我这个个人债务问题，
我也进然黑名单了，
然后他就先替我还了我个人的债务，
之前他是想帮我买房子的，
华为债务是一直拖到今年，
今年偶然间她就跟我说，
她就帮我买了一套房子嘛，
谁帮你买房子不主小孩子的妈妈不主的妈呀，
帮你买了房子，
花了多少钱？
花了60多万全款买的，
因为现在有房子了嘛，
我就想让我婆婆把三个小孩子带下来，
在县城这边读书，
肯定教育这方面的都要好一点，
们小孩子生活环境也要好一点，
因为我一直跟我的婆家公公婆婆关系都不太好，
我婆婆他们肯定是不同意的，
我的自己的爸爸奶奶他们也不同意，
一回事，
他们考虑到我把小孩子带下来肯定是增加我的负担嘛，
我面对这样一个局面的话，
我不知道应该怎么去处理，
我对我自己目前的生活状态也是特别。
不满意，
我感觉不在我的孩子跟老公这边的关系就是相处的一塌糊涂，
因为我是跟婆婆关一直都不太好，
然后我两个大女儿呢，
跟我也是不清的，
因为是婆婆的影响嘛，
到后面我就生完我儿子之后，
我就选择就近工作，
方便回去跟孩子连接一下这个关系，
这儿子跟我是很感情是很深的，
我两个女儿跟我感情是不深的，
我感觉我这个婚姻呢，
也是岌岌可危了，
我就想说是不是可以提前布局呀，
看能不能争取到这个小孩子的抚养权，
还有一个就是对我来说，
有一个觉得有一个很大的恩惠嘛，
也是工作中自己压力也会比较大，
因为能不能指导我一下，
看跟孩子怎么相处，
跟婆婆怎么相处，
跟雇主之间的一个关系怎么去平衡，
你平时是住在雇主家呢，
还是回家住呢？
是住在雇主家里，
我说的这个情况确实是属实的，
而这个雇主确确实实是小孩的妈妈，
不是别人考虑说的男性。
因为这个问题，
雇主也有跟我说过，
他为什么会送我一套房呢？
这我不是借啊，
因为他之前跟我说，
他也跟我说过，
他请了很多阿姨了。
对于她说我的话，
是她目前请的比较满意的一个，
她说她也把我当姐妹一样，
她感觉我人也挺好的，
然后比较单纯，
脾气也好，
这是她对我的评价。
我确实我的脾气是比较好的，
也是比较有耐心的，
我这个雇主真的人特别好，
他也会关心我，
我跟我老公呢，
感觉他也会跟我不应该去怎么维护我的家庭啊，
跟我老公之间怎么去相处，
像姐姐一样教导我，
那年龄比你大一点，
是不是可能要大个两三岁嘛，
还有几个小孩了，
他有两个小孩，
我再带他的大女儿，
大女儿可能现在是八岁，
那你的儿子是多大呀？
儿子是四岁，
那现在是谁带儿子呀，
是一直公公婆婆在带，
那现在雇主这边大概月薪开到多少呀？
5500，
那我是在一个可能五六线的城市里，
就是雇主也是五六线城市，
对吧，
离自己的孩子有多远呀？
回家的话四五十公里，
那也挺近的，
那一个月能回家四天，
可以带有三两次回去，
我感觉是这样的，
人生有很多很奇妙的际遇，
其实在我们看来啊，
我们是不能理解为什么雇主要送一套房子给你的，
甚至觉得这个是一件非常不可思议的事情，
但可能你就有这样的缘分，
雇主可能觉得我们用玄学一点的说法，
可能就是对你一见如故吧，
可能就是觉得跟你比较亲切，
他愿意送你一套房子，
那作为你的话，
既然受了雇主那么大的恩惠，
那我们工作的时候就是尽心尽力呗，
保证孩子的。
安全健康，
然后你说很有压力这个事情啊，
我觉得只要我秉持着善良，
尽心保证孩子平安健康，
那我也是值得的。
对于妈妈来说，
如果他经济条件真的特别好，
谁要是对他的孩子让他绝对信任，
我感觉也值得，
不顾主持，
要好好干呀，
也不要有什么太大的心理压力，
嘴上还是要学会表达，
就是说有的时候拍马屁还是要拍的，
你比如说我从来没有想过这个世界上会有一个人对我这么好，
而且还不是亲人，
有的时候就感觉到位，
人都是这样，
他在你身上花了60万，
花了70万，
他要的是一种情绪价值，
要的是一种正向的互动，
还不能说不表达这玩意儿不行的是吧？
好，
我这一方面，
我确实我感觉我个人嘴呢比较笨，
其实我这个人我是完全零社交的，
很多东西都是放在心里，
不太会表达出来，
这点孤独可以说他感觉到了，
所以说说话马屁那些，
我感觉我都有点做不来，
但是我我是认同你的，
所以说那个婚姻家庭这一块子的话，
人和人的缘分就是不一样，
他就是有的孩子跟你有缘分，
有的孩子跟你其实没有多大的缘分，
历史上也这样，
雍正皇帝他的妈妈，
他妈妈其实生了两个儿子嘛，
他就跟他大儿子雍正没有什么缘分，
没有什么感情，
跟他小儿子的感情非常好。
这个有的时候我们作为母亲也得接纳，
这一点，
不必强求，
如果说这孩子跟你没有什么亲缘，
没有什么缘分的话，
你留他，
所以他不必强求，
谁跟你有缘分你就争取谁，
这也没啥，
其实我感觉那跟两个女儿之间关系不好，
我觉得我是有责任的，
因为我感觉到有时候不是会去别对待我女儿，
她也感受得到，
我对我小孩子就是溺爱，
这两个女儿呢，
就比较冷淡，
这也是因果，
所以就是接纳，
如果你和女儿对你不亲，
可能也是因为你对人家也不亲哈，
接纳这件事情啊，
那其他还有什么问题呢？
我想因为我感觉我跟我老公对称可能也是迟早的事情，
我想看能不能提前布局，
是怎么样有利于我争取到我儿子的抚养权，
你要想争取孩子的抚养权的话，
那你做这个工作可能有一定的难度，
因为孩子不在你身边哦，
但是完全没有希望的是吗？
那也不是因为你三个孩子嘛，
三个孩子一个4岁，
因为13岁9岁，
他俩肯定就选爸不选你了，
因为他俩跟你没有缘分嘛，
那你争取孩子抚养权是有机会的啊，
只是说以后的生活安排，
如果你把孩子的抚养权争到了，
那你又是住家保姆的这样一个工作，
那孩子怎么安排呢？
也放到雇主家去养吗？
争取一下，
让我爸爸帮我带一下，
那可能还要向法官去证明。
孩子跟你离得近哦，
跟你工作的地方离得近哦，
你随时能照看得到哦。
判决孩子归属于这件事情的话，
一定是要看看谁有时间精力陪伴孩子，
而不是说我甩给我爸就行了，
甩给我妈就行了，
不行的就等孩子8现的更有把握吗？
也不是在两个女儿如果都不选你的话，
那么男孩判给你的概率还大一点，
因为等孩子8岁了，
他也未必选你哦，
我应该还是比较有把握的，
因为我儿子跟我感情是比较深的姐妹，
你现在是做出家保姆啊，
一个月是有26天不在他身边的哟，
你不要对这个事情那么大的自信啊，
明白吗？
我说这个话真的没有恶意，
就是你都会变，
4岁的孩子难道她想法不会变吗？
她长到8岁了，
她想法不会变吗？
嗯，
好明白，
好，
就这样啊，
刚刚有很多姐妹啊，
都表示了，
就是对这件事情的不可思议，
其实我心里也会有这种不可思议，
觉得这种可能性很小，
但是这世间就是千奇百怪的，
我跟你说实话好不好？
我还见过那种母女之间反目成仇，
为了争家里面的住家保姆，
就说女儿要出国了，
她什么嫁妆她都不要，
他就要带着住家保姆走，
为了能保证这住家保姆能跟他一起出国的话，
他甚至愿意出钱让他住家保姆的孩子留学，
跟他去同一个国家给他办签证，
你们信不信，
这个世界上就是。
这不的呀，
人跟人之间的关系就是这么奇怪，
他跟他妈妈感情特别好，
但为什么就反目成仇呢？
因为他俩就想争那个住家保姆，
有的住家保姆是呃，
带完了第二代，
然后在第三代，
在家里的话是地位老高了，
有的为了能够让这个住家保姆别辞职的话，
直接给他儿子儿媳妇安排工作，
安排在家里工资，
有的甚至说出国了，
他都得带着住家保姆出去，
出国了之后都得给他住家保姆的家里的孩子啊，
什么安排去留学，
安排去国外去工作去，
刚刚有人是短去看多了，
你看你就是世界上就是人和人的缘分，
就是千奇百怪，
你把以前看那个桃姐那个电影，
你看那个住家保姆是带完了姐姐带弟弟，
带完了弟弟带妹妹，
然后带完了一代又一代，
在朱家的话，
在他们家几十年了工作，
人家后来刘德华演的那个角色不也是当干妈这么看嘛，
刚刚有个朋友说，
那他待了几年，
付出了多少，
那能一样吗？
是我刚开始我也觉得这事儿，
我甚至心里面都会有点怀疑，
这个女老板是不是有点儿那啥，
跟我们不太一样，
我甚至心里都会有这个想法，
但是我这个工作呢，
我必须要当事人他描述的这个前提，
我要在这个前提之下去帮他分析，
是这个意思啊。
记得点赞关注哦。